a question is how many times do you have
to shuffle the cards a deck of cards to
mix it up i mean by shuffling probably
what you mean by shuffling you cut them
about in half you go like that you push
them together right and
how many times do you have to do that
until the cards get all mixed up and uh
there's a practical answer the answer is
about seven and uh
and it's not i think it or it feels that
way it's a theorem in contrast there's
another way that people shuffle cards uh
they shuffle cards this way
you've seen people shuffle cards that
way that's how our chapel goes okay well
and in india they do it this way
it's the same you can see it's the same
little dropping little clumps one after
another and so lots of some people
shuffle that way and the answer to how
many of those shuffles does it take to
mix up cards is about ten thousand
so
it makes a difference uh
yes it makes a difference there's a
third wave shuffling cards that is used
in tournament poker games and is used in
monte carlo i call that shmushing so
that's this method of shuffling cards
you've probably
seen somebody do that you might have
done it yourself and then you gather
them up and hope for the best if you
smush for a minute
it passes all the tests we've ever
thrown at it um if you shmush for 30
seconds it's sort of on the edge but
seems okay and less than that
it's uh it starts failing tests and
somebody could make money against your
guest cards right
suppose you had a scheme for shuffling
cards one of these schemes and you
wanted to think about is it working is
it random or what am i talking about if
it was a few cards suppose you had four
cards and you had some scheme for
shuffling them i don't know some
specific scheme you could just try it a
lot with four cards there are only 24
possibilities the top card can be any of
four cards the next can be any of three
that's four times three is twelve times
two is twenty four and then this is
forced to go left so you could just do
it a thousand times and see to all 24
possibilities occur about equally likely
but with 52 cards they're about
10 to the 68 arrangements of a deck of
52 cards it's more than the number of
particles in the universe okay so one
way of defining randomness is to say all
arrangements should be about equally
likely i'll say a sort of more practical
version of it suppose that you had a
scheme for shuffling cards and then we
were playing a card game and you had to
guess at the cards one at a time as i
turn them over so for example
you know
take a guess what do you think the top
card is six of spades
maybe upside down not so bad righty not
so bad
i think you know six nine it could be
okay but suppose
as in a card game or in a casino the
cards were turned up one at a time and
somebody tried to guess what they were
now
we know now that the nine of spades is
out of the deck so you're not going to
guess that again
what do you think the next one is jack
of diamonds
not so good okay so
no but of course it's not so good your
chance of being right on the first card
is one in 52 if the cards were perfectly
mixed
your chance of being right on the next
card is one in 51 then one in 50 if you
have a good memory and if you have a
really good memory if the cards are all
turned face up you would know what the
last card is for sure
it's the matching nine if the cards were
perfectly shuffled
you expect to get
152 plus 1 and 51 plus 1 and 50 etc
right in going through the deck one at a
time and that adds up to about four and
a half so if somebody could remember and
was guessing but the cards were well
mixed you can get about four and a half
right on average if you don't riffle
shuffle enough if you riffle shuffle
four or five times somebody can get nine
or ten cards right on average anybody
would say that's not random riffle
shuffle is this guy
you ripple them together is the way we
say it they sometimes do it on the table
this way you know
a casino dealer will do will do that
that's riffle this is called overhand
and the other one i call smooshing i
wanted to say it's not just experimental
that gives us these numbers i gave you
seven shuffles it's math and i wanted to
try to explain
a theorem
and i think this is one that i can
explain without writing anything down
let's see if i make it i'm going to take
a very simple shuffle which is take the
top card off and put it in at random you
might put it back on top you might put
it back second from the top you might
put it on the bottom it's intuitively
obvious that if you did that a lot
the cards would get all mixed up i mean
it's a silly way of shuffling but it is
like a riffle shuffle where you just
happen to have cut off one card you know
i'm i'm riffle shuffling this one card
into this big deck
putting it in at random the deck starts
out in order you know ace of spades two
of spades three of spades
whatever and there's some card at the
bottom i'm going to suppose it's the
king of hearts so the deck is in order
you know the order of the deck it's it's
in order that's how it came from the
factory yes yes or you might have
written down guys in casinos you know
record them as they come off right how
it came from the factory and now you're
taking the top card in off and poking it
in at random
and
you just do that a lot okay
poke poke poke
now
eventually
because of the rules some card will go
underneath that original bottom card
the king of hearts there it is on the
bottom eventually if you wait long
enough a card goes underneath the bottom
card how long does that take well the
chance of a card going underneath the
bottom card is 1 in 52 because there are
52 places it can go
and so the chance of the event happening
is 1 and 52. therefore it takes about 52
pokes
on the average to have that happen okay
and now keep going like an idiot and
eventually a second card goes underneath
the king of hearts when i put that
second card underneath
the king of hearts so there are two
cards there
even if i told you hey it's on poke 503
i just poked the second card underneath
the king of hearts
it's equally likely that the two cards
underneath the king of hearts are
in order low high or high low because
i'm poking the card in at random i could
have put it above the card that's on the
bottom or below it i'm poking them in at
random now keep poking eventually a
third card goes underneath the
king of hearts
there are two cards previously this one
there are two cards this one goes in
here here or here at random so all six
orders are equally likely every time you
put a card in given as long as you're
putting it in at random the
the cards underneath the king of hearts
are in a completely random order
i hope that's intuitive and it's it's
true it makes sense it makes sense and
now look at what happens the
keep poking the the king of hearts event
slowly moves up it never goes down it
might stay where it is if i put a card
above it it stays where it is but if i
put a card below it it moves up by one
so eventually the king of hearts comes
to the top
by
induction by the argument we've been
doing this all the 51 cards are in a
random order when i put the king of
hearts in at random the whole deck is
random exactly random at that at that
moment every arrangement is equally
likely so that is not only intuitive
it's an exact mathematical fact but i
hope it makes sense i think it makes
sense and now so now you can just ask
how long does that take
well
it takes 52 pokes for the first card to
go under there's the king of hearts on
the bottom then i put a card underneath
it so now there are two places the the
next card could go so it's it's it's
it's it's two out of 52. so it takes 52
over two pokes and then it takes 52 over
three pokes for the third card to go
under so it's 52 plus 52 over two plus
52 over three
and that
answer is
well it's
what is it it's 52 times log of 52 which
is around
200 or so you know so it takes about 200
of these pokes
if you shuffle fewer times if you
shuffle five or six times uh it it
really
somebody can really make money against
you
in a card guessing experiment if you
shuffle you know 10 or 11 times it's not
worth the wear and tear on your shoe
leather standing there in the casino if
you're counting cards it's just as close
to random as it could be of course it's
never perfectly random you know you have
to shuffle infinitely often to make it
there's still some trace of the original
order but it vanishes exponentially fast
so wonderful question let me
try to match you with an answer
uh
the model that
the seven shuffle is based on i'm gonna
say it as a as a slightly more mathy
thing